tutor banged up Whitmer on Dan bongino's
show just yesterday Tudor the host of
The View the left wing house had some
thoughts on women voters vote for the
GOP and I'd like you to listen to this
and just get your thoughts on it on the
other side check this out
I read a poll just yesterday that white
Republican Suburban women are now going
to vote Republican why it's almost like
roaches voting for raid right
dude I only got about 30 seconds left
here but roaches voting for rage kind of
disgusting isn't it
it is this is the deplorables moment of
2016 and that will drive more people to
the polls they won't talk about it it
will be a shock come Tuesday I mean this
attack this attack on moms who just want
to protect their kids I mean I can tell
you as a new father like that is my
freaking job more than this is my job I
think about it I actually think about it
every morning every single morning
because when I'm doing this when I'm
preparing for the show and I'm sitting
there with Luke and Justin and I do an
hour with the two of them while David's
doing some other stuff in the morning
and I sit on the couch with two of them
and I've got uh well now I prop Justin
up on the couch I build a little little
castle for him with blankets and I've
got I've got Luke in the docat and I'm
sitting there and I'm going through the
stories of the day and and I really am
thinking about how I have to fight
harder for good ideas and for Freedom so
that these kids don't grow up in a world
that is worse and and we have been
heading to a world that is worse so when
Sunny hosting and the rest of these
people they attack the parents the
parents who didn't want their kids
genitals chopped up their parents who
wanted their kids to go to school who
wanted them not to have masks so that
they could see teachers faces so that
they could mimic the way that they spoke
that's actually how you start speaking
as a child but they're going to just
keep going and then what are they going
to do and this is going to be the
grandest of all tricks and these people
have plenty of tricks up their sleeve
but assuming that the Red Wave happens
tomorrow suddenly you know what's going
to happen on Wednesday you're going to
be allowed to talk about election
interference again you're going to be
allowed and encouraged actually to
promote that there was fraud in the
election and everything else much like
say I don't know Stacey Abrams has been
making a career of where Hillary Clinton
did for four years under Trump Etc et
cetera check out this headline from
Politico this is this past weekend the
2020 presidential election was Rife with
allegations of voting machine hacks that
were later debunked yet there are real
risks that hackers could tunnel into
voting equipment and other election
infrastructure to try to undermine
Tuesday's vote man they are seeding the
ground do you get it do you see it I'm
sorry if you see it because if you're
going oh [ __ ] I don't want to see it
because once I see it I can't unsee it
but you see it right you see it
so Wednesday morning after the red wave
that is what's going to happen and
mainstream media will be running around
with election interference and what
happened